Salut
Nous sommes l'organisation United Voices
Nous sommes les voix que vous avez entendues
votre enfance vous nous avez entendu dans certains de
vos jouets et vous nous écoutez dans de nombreux
produits que vous utilisez quotidiennement nous voulons
ont le droit de décider comment ils sont utilisés
nos voix et décider quoi faire avec
elles
[Musique]
Je suis le roi Julien de Madagascar et un
à partir de maintenant tu seras aujourd'hui
nous sommes mieux informés mieux communiqués
et la société tend à standardiser ses
goûts et modes de vie
[Musique]
les changements alimentent le système
L'intelligence artificielle avec des voix qui
existent sur les plates-formes que nous avons été
pendant des années augmentant même le même
diffuseurs et tous les créateurs de
contenu nous parlons de la loi
humain d'utiliser la voix sans votre
consentement et mis à part le fait que vous n'avez pas
décision sur le droit d'utiliser votre
voix ou votre interprétation
pour quelque chose de mieux n'oublions pas un instant
seconde que tout va mieux
quand on le fait ensemble
comprenons que rien ne doit être
parfait que la chose la plus importante que nous soyons
clairement une organisation pro humaine
dans lequel nous voulons que les humains suivent
en tête et que nous
nous voulons être ceux qui les utilisent
outils et non que ces outils
ils nous utilisent
[Musique]